salut aujourd'hui je suis avec une corde
à vous la voyez d'ici au sida but tuer
cernés par les caméras
et c'est le succès de la wii en
contre-plongée c'est vrai que l'euro
montait un peu regardé l cardin c'est
une comédienne humoriste nous plein de
choses je peux dire ça peut pas aller eu
la chance de partir enfin la chance tu
as créé la chance que qu'elle a décidé
de partir en australie tu es parti
combien de temps partie 9,9 fois
indépendant bébé aurait mal était revenu
en simple d'ailleurs au centre de plein
de souvenirs de jeux des transitions de
ouf
tu m'as vu tu comprends pourquoi
j'aimerais s'il te plaît and que tu
prennes un de tes souvenirs atypique un
truc marquant un truc rigolo qui était
arrivé en australie et que je peux pas
connaître
là ça veut dire lequel un bon résultat
c'est bon tu t'es fixé sur un souvenir
particulier ok c'est parfait je peux pas
le connaître
alors j'en prendrais annonce alors parce
que du coup la tête le connaître ou
alors
ah c'est parce que d'en appeler paris
sur facebook comme steve à l' écoute sur
tout ce que tu as raconté sur neuf mois
ouais on soutenir oui c'est vrai ben du
coup je gagne à na waie je ne peux pas
connaître cette anecdote c'est sûr et
certain à 100%
ok je vais noté moi des choses
j'imagine que tu pourrais
potentiellement raconté dans cette
anecdote par exemple je dédie une grosse
bêtise mais si je pense que tu vas me
raconter une soirée je peux marquer
bière faite ou des choses comme ça
j'essayais de de pressentir en fait de
prédire un petit peu le ce type
d'anecdote que tu as à me raconter et
après on comparera à la fin comme ça
marche comme ça ils vont voir ce que je
vais écrire avance tu vois pas ce que
j'écris moi
je vais essayer de noter des mots comme
ça pour prédire un peu ça
je pense que tu vas parler d'un truc
d'un truc comme ça donc je vais l'écrire
ici
je vais pas me demande si tu vas pas me
parler de quelque chose comme ça et
alors j'ai quasiment un flash par le
dernier je vais marquer mais je vais pas
voir faire voire même le jeu qui soit
surpris si c'est bon je t'ai la jetée là
et je t'écoute ja de konaté d'histoire
on l'a dit qu'ils me racontent comme si
j'étais un pote et fait semblant mais
semblant de bien m'aimer sais pas s'ils
n'arrivent en australie baraque au toit
un bien ce que je peux pas faire en
france à peut-être lui en fait me suis
occupé pendant quinze jours deux
dauphins sauvages de dauphin se ferait
avec je savais que tu avais élever un
bébé kangourou 600 km a été occupée de
dauphins sauvages comme ça se fait dans
le hasard non mais je voulais monter
tours temps je voulais faire un beau
trip la côte ouest où un fils très bien
et donc je savais que lamont climat ya
dans ses longues plages y avait des
engins dont je voulais y aller et en
tapant sur internet je suis rendu compte
qu'on pouvait être volontaires pour
travailler avec les rangers
j'ai postulé j'ai travaillé d'accord oui
mon petit tout de suite
vous n'êtes pas payé non non
ce type d automne ils viennent tous les
matins on cote quand tu dis on n'est pas
payé ça s'appelle du volontariat ou du
bénévolat qui peut peut-être parce que
peut-être que tu te doutes des mots que
j'écris maintenant ok d'accord ok et
puis et donc non mais après c'est en
gros ce que c'est que ces attaques et
que du coup j'avais un bon sens qui
gâteries une trentaine de dauphins qui
viennent tous les matins même journée
sur 7
là j'avais j'ai un 25e journée
particulièrement déjà 21 parce que je ne
me reconnaissais s'est jeté son très
long et il s'appelle windows comme dans
ses bagages ball haïtien picolo picolo
ans et ça fait une bonne affaire pour
toi qui te reconnaissent et d'ailleurs
et quand tu veux des titres reconnais
c'est vraiment super bien j'ai
l'impression que les objets pas
forcément aux autres
montréjeau le pékin moyen d'accords et
donc c'est chouette a en tout cas de
choix d'avoir eu la démarche de
s'inscrire comme ça après des rangers
placez vous feront donc en fait tu as
fait tu as fait on pourrait dire du
bénévolat
plus que du volontariat c'est la même
chose avec les dauphins dont un pitre
connaissait et ou ex athlète qui coule
d'accord les gens ils ont vu que j'avais
déjà écrit bénévolat des internautes ont
dit que j'avais déjà écrit dauphin alors
oui j'écris un troisième truc en fait
est ce que tu peux me dire le nom d'un
des rangers s'est par exemple
rappelle qu en fait le seul donc à cette
histoire c'est le nom du dauphin piccolo
mois sur le bloc notes j'avais écrit
colloque n'ont jamais juste écrit ça
piccolo mais si c'est quoi ton actu en
ce moment qu'est ce que des ce qu'on
peut dire sur toi binger se joue en duo
avec ma soeur oui ils s'appellent des
dommages un bon jour là le 9 mars à
bordeaux
dans ce cadre n'était pas du côté de
l'humour est d'accord grande nouvelle en
exclusivité je peux vous annoncer qu'on
va jouer au festival assez cool
ah bah oui c'est cool grave donc donc si
vous n'avez pas bien compris annales a
une soeur jumelle qui s'appelle sophie
regard du coup elles font un duo elles
font un duo mais comme elles sont qu une
à la fois sur scène tu as l'impression
que c'est un one
non je déconne qui s'accroît j'étais
assez drôle
tellement drôle mais tu écoutes j'avais
aussi noté dans le carnet qui n'arrête
jamais et quant à nous rendez vous
demain à 17h pour prochain mentale vlog
chao cm